razzia heute morgen hier in berlin seit
6 uhr durchsucht das lka mit hilfe des
sek mehrere wohnungen unter anderem in
den stadtteilen neukölln und schöneberg
es soll mindestens zwei festnahmen
gegeben haben auswertungen von enco chat
daten zufolge soll es um drogen in nicht
unerheblicher menge gehen ja einen
klaren bezug soll es nach bild
informationen bei der razzia nicht geben
bis zum juli 2020 war enke chat die app
mit der die unterwelt am liebsten
kommunizierte das handy war abhörsicher
und nicht von der polizei zu ordnen so
konnten kriminelle ihre geschäfte im
geheim koordinieren und jetzt diese mega
wir schalten direkt zu annika rage
unserer kolleginnen die vereine der
objekte steht die oder ihr untersucht
werden gerade annika was kannst du uns
dort über die ermittlungen laufen sagen
ja patricia du hast es richtig gesagt
bis vor kurzem bis vor wenigen minuten
liefen hier die ermittlungen seit sechs
uhr morgens also insgesamt dreieinhalb
stunden das lka war hier vor ort die
soko büchse und
gemeinsam mit dem sek wurde neben hier
in berlin heute morgen ab 6 uhr morgens
mehrere objekte durchsucht und unter
anderem hier in schöneberg in der
bülowstraße hinter mir durch die tür ist
das sek gestürmt vor dreieinhalb stunden
eben in folge dieser auswertung von enco
chats es wurden nach unseren
informationen zwei menschen festgenommen
und ein porsche panamera im wert von
ungefähr 140000 euro
beschlagnahmt insgesamt ging es dabei
wohl um drogen von nicht unerheblicher
menge und wie hier eben auch schon
gesagt habe laut meinem kollegen axel
ihre der heute morgen hier auch vor ort
war gibt es noch
keine hinweise auf einen klaren bezug
becker jetzt ist es relativ ruhig bei
dir
dort vor ort aussieht einmal mit leben
genau also ich kann man einmal bis in
das bild weiter also eben durch diese
graue tür ist heute morgen das sek und
das lka eben inklusive der soko büchse
gestürmt heute morgen um 6 jetzt ist es
hier total ruhig das ist auch eine
sowieso ganz ruhige gegend können einmal
hier umschwenken wir haben hier zwei
autos stehen aber das ist eine ganz
normale wohngegend ein ganz
unscheinbares haus in dem man sowas
nicht erwarten würde aber wie gesagt
heute morgen gab es dann eben hier diese
große razzia bei der ist eben um ganz
ganz hohe wert beträge geht und eben
keine unerheblichen mengen drogen eine
garage uns zugeschaltet hier in berlin
schöneberg schöneburg dort eine mega
razzia schöneberg und in neukölln so er
ist es richtig hier in berlin in der
hauptstadt seit heute morgen es geht um
große mengen drogen annika danke für die
information